الفكرة برمتها هي أننا نقوم بالكثير من
العمل لجعله يبدو وكأننا لم نفعله مع أحد ،
لذلك أخذنا كل الجمال المكرر بالنعمة
واستمرارية
البطاقات الجمالية والكلاسيكية ثم نجمع ذلك
مع أحدث وأكبر
النظم الميكانيكية الهندسية بحيث
القدرة قابلة للتطبيق اليوم ،
كل مشروع على حدة يجلب
تقنية جديدة
لدمج عمليات جديدة لتجربة
تحديات جديدة حتى الكثير من عملائنا الذين
لم يدركوا أبدًا ما هو الملاءمة والانتهاء ،
كل ذلك يتماشى مع الكمال ، لكن كل شيء مذهل
أنك لن تراك أبدًا  لم يدرك ذلك أبدًا ،
فعلى سبيل المثال ، سوف يقوم بمسح مركبة بالليزر
من الأربعينيات بحيث يكون لدينا عنصر بيانات CAD ،
وبالتالي يمكننا
التحكم فيه رقميًا ، وعلينا جمع
العمليات التي تتراوح من
الفضاء الرائد إلى مائة وحدة
تحكم في مجموعة بطاريات تسلا
لذلك ، تبدأ العملية عمومًا مع
عميل يعرب عن اهتمامه
بمركبة محددة للغاية بمجرد حصولنا على الضوء الأخضر
، فقد وضعت APB على شبكة من
الصيادين الذين يعملون  بالنسبة لنا ، تحتاج إلى
العثور على هذا التوازن الدقيق من الزنجار ولكن لا
تتحلل في بعض الأحيان ، حدث البحث عن السيارة
حرفيًا خلال 72 ساعة في
أوقات أخرى ذهبنا فيها لمدة عامين
واضطررنا إلى التخلي عن المهمة بمجرد أن نبدأ
العملية ،
أود أن أقول  متوسط وقت بناء الشخص ال
همل هو في أي مكان من 18 إلى 24 شه
ًا ، لذلك لتحقيق ما نفعله ، يج
أن نكون ذكيين نوعًا ما وق
يلًا من MacGyver لمزج ال
قنيات والعمليات المختلفة التي يع
ل بها الرجال الذين يعملون معنا وينجحون حقًا  هنا ربما
لم يكن لديه خبرة مهنية في
هذا المجال ، لكن شغفهم
كان كثيرًا من الناس ينظرون إلى المشاريع المهجورة ويبحثون عن
سبب
إنفاق أي شخص على الأرض كل هذا الوقت والمال على
شيء يبدو سيئًا للغاية ، إنه ليس
للجميع وهذا جزء
بالنسبة لي ، إنه
رومانسي للغاية بسبب هذا الإحساس بالتساؤل ،
فإن الإحساس بالتاريخ بأنهم يستحضرون
كل ما نقوم به يكون
عاطفيًا بشكل واضح ويجب أن يكون كذلك أو أننا لا
نقوم بعمل جيد
[تصفيق  ]